we are learning more about a horrific
crime that left
two children dead on friday and a mother
facing murder charges
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live at metro headquarters
and madison there was a candlelight
vigil tonight for those babies right
yeah so that is correct when we arrived
at the complex earlier today we spoke to
a neighbor
who said that she frequently saw the
mother of two with her kids around the
courtyard
the mother of the child who was a black
female in her late 20s was taken into
custody and will be booked for two
counts of open murder metro police
arrested amanda sharp jefferson friday
afternoon
after there was substantial evidence
that she murdered her own two children
in the arrest report that we obtained
today sharp jefferson told police
she lived alone did not have any
children and did not know who their
father was
she also reportedly told police that
someone else put the children
and all their belongings in her
apartment the children's father jaquan
singleton
said he came home around noon on friday
to find his two daughters
one-year-old rose singleton and
two-month-old lilly singleton
dead the report said both children were
in a baby swing in the living room area
singleton also told police he had not
been home all day and that their mother
sharp jefferson was the only person
alone with them
do you seem maybe a little bit off she
would just go downstairs walk by and go
back up
to her house and the incident took place
at apartment number five which you can
see right up there and as of
now there is a candlelight vigil in
honor of the two children
that lost their lives during the 911
could be heard
asking what did you do apparently to the
mother
he also told officers when he entered to
the apartment the children's mother told
him to be quiet
after he found them according to the
report sharp jefferson made a statement
about the children's
organs being worth a lot of money
and sharp jefferson is expected in court
tomorrow morning and once again she is
charged
with two counts of open murder reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news now